bien nous voici devant l'ambassade de
France à l'instant exa monsur pou après
la deè
s
deanceésent
de
és
madameur monsieur le Président
accepteriez-vous de N dire qu
estadadamesieur le président ques sont
vos impressions après 24 heur passé àos
et bien voyez je trouve que les choses
se déroulent comme je le souhaitais
c'est-à-dire dans un climat de grande
franchise et nous avons fait le tour
d'un certain nombre de
questions nous avons surtout constaté
qu'il en restait encore beaucoup
d'autres de telle sorte qu'on sera
probablement amené à trouver dans
l'emploi du temps plus d'heur que prévu
pour les
conversations mais des deux côtés il y a
la volonté de se parler avec beaucoup de
clarté de netteté de franchise et par
conséquent ça ne peut qu'aider aux
propres relations entre au développement
des relations entre la France et l'Union
soviétique et je crois dans une bonne
mesure à l'éclaircissement des question
générales et en particulier européenes
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président bon
appétit mes hommages madame il y aura au
total 40 personnes à se quelques
instants après le président de la
République et Madame Pidou arrivent les
invités
soviétiques et d'abord dans la même
voiture monsieur bref Monsieur G
monsieur monsieur bref sort le premier
nous allons tenter de nous approcher de
lui et de lui poser des questions au nom
de la télévision française secrire
général ques sont vos impressions sur
cord am Fran et très
ule puis vient monsieur CIN Premier
ministre votre impression à vous
ambiance très bonne difficile d'imaginer
mieux il faut dire que les dirigeants
soviétiques n'ont pas pour habitude de
se rendre dans une ambassade étrangère
il y a là par conséquent une volonté
évidente de montrer qu'on attage
beaucoup d'importance à Moscou à la
visite du président pompid et qu'on veut
l'honorer le plus possible la table est
somptueusement décorée de Ros ces fleurs
sont d'ailleurs arrivées spécialement de
Nice par avion au menu et bien au menu
fois gras turbo RTI veau salade fromage
glace fruit et bien entendu du champagne
français